US ambassador to Germany Richard
Grinnell is continuing to raise tempers
in Berlin on Tuesday he accused the
German government of court reducing its
already unacceptable commitments to
military readiness unquote calling it a
worrisome signal to Germany's NATO
allies in fact the new budget features a
small rise in both absolute military
expenditures and the percentage of
German GDP spent on defense but those
outlays aren't enough for Grinnell or
his boss US president Donald Trump
Germany is well short of the 2% target
agreed to at a NATO summit in 2014 and
expenditures in coming years are set to
remain 25 billion euros below what
Germany's own defense minister says she
needs German Chancellor Angela Merkel
defended the budget plan as being part
of a slow but steady hike in military
spending via Mohammed Disney I this year
we have one point three five percent of
GDP according to growth projections for
NATO expenditures and we've gone from
one point one eight to one point three
five in only a few years despite robust
growth and next year we'll increase the
amount to a projected one point three
seven percent of GDP and understand the
German government is annoyed at what
they see as Grinnell's meddling a
leading member of Michals coalition
partners the Social Democrats shot back
mr. Grinnell is a complete diplomatic
zero members of the opposition have even
demanded that the controversial
ambassador be expelled that's a near
impossibility the tensions over defense
spending between Berlin and America's
ambassador are likely to continue off
more on these new tensions political
correspondent Simon Young is with us in
the studio good morning Simon let's
start off if we could with the calls for
Grinnell the US ambassador to be
expelled they come from a pro-business
German politician from a party committed
to the transatlantic relationship are we
in new political territory here that's
right both young kabuki the the depth
deputy leader of the FDP calling for
ambassador Grinnell to be declared
persona non grata I think it's just a
measure of how ugly this dispute has got
and the ambassador has got politicians
here in Germany of all parties saying
that his interference in this domestic
question of Germany's budgets Penny's
completely unacceptable
calling it provocation and so on and you
know that's even from those who supports
an increase in military spending as we
know a president Trump has long accused
Germany of the freeloading on a US
military power you know and the tone may
well get even tougher in the coming
weeks in in two weeks time the NATO
member countries are due to gather for a
commemoration of the 7070 anniversary of
the founding of NATO and where's that
happening Washington DC so you know this
is a difficult times for NATO diplomacy
okay and and you're talking about tone
coming from the ambassador's of
residence here in Berlin it it's not
just the military budget in the past
we've heard about the Iran treaty from
Ambassador Grinnell the sharply
criticized and most recently over the
past a few days the call for Grinnell
warning that the US would scale back
intelligence sharing over the 5g network
if Huawei the Chinese check giant was
involved this is a long laundry list
that he's tweeting on quite often he's
tweeting and indeed it seems that
ambassador Grinnell wrote a letter to
the German economy Minister Peter admire
making this threat effectively as you
say that if Germany chooses one way for
5g that could affect intelligence
sharing of course Washington believes
that Huawei the Chinese company is too
close to the regime in Beijing and that
sensitive data could leak again a big
pushback from the German side the
Foreign Minister icon masse said you
know that's unacceptable and Germany
will do all it can to ensure the
security of its key infrastructure like
the five
network that's just being rolled out
here you know some say this is really
about business and that the US side
would have no problem for instance if
Germany chose Qualcomm the u.s. 5g
equipment make it okay Simon thanks so
very much for your comments and insights
on on these issues this morning Simon
Young there from our political desk